and border patrol officials meantime say
they encountered more than
171 thousand migrants in march
exponentially up month over month year
over year according to preliminary data
a new associated press poll meantime
indicates large-scale disapproval
of the way president biden is handling
the immigration surge
40 percent of those surveyed disapprove
of his response just 24 percent
approve the influx is providing
smugglers
opportunity to sneak more illegal drugs
across the border
correspondent alex hogan reports tonight
from mcallen texas
surging numbers of migrants at the u.s
mexico border
thousands in search of a new life in
america
hopefully the u.s government can help us
border agencies say the massive influx
of foot traffic means fewer eyes on
securing the border
so far into the year along the rio
grande valley the drug enforcement
administration has already seized
28 thousand pounds of marijuana more
than 800 pounds of cocaine
75 pounds of heroin and more than 4
thousand pounds of meth
more troubling is the increase of
fentanyl the seizures of fentanyl that
were made
from 2019 to 2020 could essentially kill
half the population of america
what we made so far and on pace to seize
this year
could kill the other half in recent
months border agents also stopped two
men
on the terrorist watch list agencies
along the border calling for more
manpower and financial support
easter sunday hundreds of migrants
crossed into the rio grande valley
among them a mother who collapsed from
dehydration after
surrendering to border agents she'd
given birth just
one month ago more than 18 thousand kids
are in custody after taking the
dangerous journey alone
i want to be with my mom to create room
the customs and border protection center
in donna texas
is expanding while other facilities open
up across the country
critics argue white house policies
encourage the migration the
administration however points to a
crisis in the northern triangle an
envoy will travel to guatemala and el
salvador this week to speak with local
leaders
our goal has to be to address these root
causes
these root drivers of migration if we're
going to find
a long-term solution to this challenge
here inside the dea's drug warehouse in
mcallen texas the shelves are stacked
with
about 9 million dollars worth of
marijuana but agents say
the smuggling and the narcotics that are
seized will only
increase if these agencies along the
border do not have adequate and more
funding in terms of financial aid and
manpower
brett alex hogan along the border
mcallen texas alex thanks